what does this call the sync an audio
sync sync
sync sync cl guys sync clap let's leave
this in the cut okay and three two one
oof what a clap
all right all right sorry about that um
let's just uh
let's just get started i wrote you guys
a song oh really thoughtful here i'll
kick you off with this poppin of my
natty here
oh that just feels good
is that a natural light
it's a natural la croix
aqua okay i thought you were you were
taking me back to the college days
all right uh here we go um
this is stacy's mom
[Music]
welcome back to the gourd art digital
podcast
how's everybody doing great oh whoa i'm
so excited feeling good
i hope that you guys are having a great
day i hope all the listeners are having
a great day and uh well thanks for
joining us once again
um in this round
we've got some uh very special guests
who do we have today we've got fenner
is this your second time on the podcast
fenner third time the big three wow the
big 3-0 can you believe it
um
i can't believe it i can't
it's not believable i'm not going to
believe that this is your third time
yeah so it's the second fair enough yeah
is my second time we've got jordan allen
okay i was expecting applause
just to be consistent here no more than
anything sorry oh man yeah now it's like
now i regret it now it just feels like
it's like it's your third time here you
want one more you really want one give
me one more just get it over with okay
all right
thank you wow thank you so much okay
great great great all right let's keep
it going and then we've got nick lauren
clap don't clap
from this guy no clapping no clapping
only booze i need i'm fed by a negative
i think
yeah i need haters in order to be
motivated let's try that again with a
boo can we please no and now we've got
nick laurent
nick gets up every morning and is just
about to crush haters
just negative comments just
asking for it
uh have we posted recently on the uh the
uh comment hall of fame
any good ones since we last talked about
good ones yeah i feel like
with the ai videos they're just so many
like hot takes and so many emotions
i saw one person say why why have you
guys created hell
that's beautiful yeah man there's like
it's so funny because like i think most
people are just like
stoked to see these these ideas be made
you know they're like oh yeah we can
appreciate you know they're just they're
just trying new stuff like it's not
dangerous but then there's a whole
subset that are either like
you guys are bringing humanity and then
the next into the like skynet war
it's all going to be on you you're
laughing now but like we're going to
look back on this yeah dawn of the end
of like this like epoch sierra
it's like once you make an influencer
that can influence other ai robots then
you're screwed
because they need a leader jake ziera
goddard jetski hey oh okay so i want to
talk about this yeah the last time
fenner was in the podcast
we uh
we talked about something we talked
about whether or not
uh the audience could influence zera
uh to see if she would then like take on
features traits ideals
things of this nature
from the audience so we did a very
simple experiment we asked everybody in
the comments uh
to start commenting
regarding zira's life as a professional
jet ski racer
wow and sure and sure enough after
enough of these comments she started to
take on
this aspect of her life as if she now
believed that she was a professional jet
ski racer that's crazy um
she's been doing and she's been doing
posts she's about jet skis like she
lives
she did a story the other day but she
has nowhere to write it right that's the
sad part
you know for now
for now yeah here here's one here's one
from
what two days ago i finally got my jet
ski
um
and she posted a story about this
earlier
um
that's crazy man
yeah so so we've been able i don't know
how this is functioning on like the ai
node side
but
we've been able to
uh
[Music]
say hey jet skis and then
sure enough crazy jet skis sam's not
here so we can't speak to this but i
know that um for the comments like the
replies to comments that's not automated
at this point like it's not automated
sam is like typing he's like okay here's
a cool comment he throws it in the same
sierra ai yeah and then that makes the
answer and then but you have to like
still like manually put in
the comment because
we don't i mean someday maybe we can get
there but
it's not in the pipeline right now to
like go through instagram and then like
weed through comments and then auto
reply i think instagram actually blocks
that yeah okay
so we had a guy email us we had a few
people email us about this now
people that say they can automate sierra
um
basically through
uh api use and then through python dude
that's so cool uh primarily through
python and then a few other methods is
what some people that have reached out
to us have said so
like they can automate her further
was always kind of like a joke right
yeah like it's pretty apparent in the
video it ends with like it's like okay i
tell i press the button then peter does
the waters peter and you know like so
like the buttons the joke but the idea
is real i mean it's basically all
automated you just have to manually like
manually play it right here so it's like
you know
it's just flipped like we're doing the
robot work basically yeah um but dude
that's so cool that people are reaching
out we should i mean i don't know if sam
wants to like keep sarah going and keep
like he's getting pretty famous yeah she
is it's crazy
how many followers does she have now
she was i think she was at 1300 when we
launched the video
she's got she's got a uh 1100 followers
on which wait on instagram on instagram
no no on instagram already successful i
just refreshed she's at 16 000.
yeah hey 16. a difference a moment can
make her she can start doing ad
institutions now right that's that's the
that's the ultimate is like i have an ai
that makes brand integration money for
me
but would you ever want to turn off the
filter for the comment responses
because that checks and balance system
obviously is i make sure she's not
saying anything but yeah yeah
well i'm
you don't want to be like
you know patently horrible
obviously
um
or lately horrible but you know you
there is a little bit of i think
um
creative space for the fact that she is
an ai like it is an ai
you know and so
there might be some things that like
she's gonna say
that would be obviously like not okay
for people to say
and obviously we need to balance that
and be aware of that and like you know
apply all levels of scrutiny to that but
there is a there is a thing that is
weird in the sense that like this isn't
this is not a person this is a computer
so
you know that that sort of
like that has to be taken into
consideration as well um but obviously
we can't just have it errantly posting
anything all the time however it wants
to that would be not only irresponsible
but also would probably
light some
light some fires pretty quickly that you
don't really want to light um
historically we've seen ais when they're
left to their own devices they get kind
of racist they get pretty racist pretty
quickly they're kind of like really
depressed and i mean
is already depressed as you said
she's definitely depressed she
definitely has mental there's definitely
some mental health uh issues you just
said something though like we don't want
her getting cancelled but like
don't we isn't that like the final
yeah
she makes it to the top she she has her
like moment to shine she she
slaps she slaps chris rock and then
and then she says some
bad stuff and gets canceled but that's
like the life cycle of an influencer it
is it is all of yeah
but many of them yeah it is interesting
though that like
that we
we immediately are like applying
our humanity to it
yeah big time like this is a computer
if a computer says some f'ed up stuff
you know it's like
i don't know what to do with that that's
actually a good point because it's
effectively a mirror isn't it so if it's
saying bad things yeah we gotta kind of
look at ourselves and say you know
exactly but like i think it reflects
more on humanity than anything else
honestly
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen one place that we
go to anytime we need stock assets is
story blocks that's right courtesy of
today's sponsor storyblocks anytime we
need high quality 4k b-roll images audio
after effects templates and more is
storyblocks why well there's a bunch of
reasons the first reason is they have a
virtually unlimited library that means
every time we go to their site there is
something new for what we need for our
videos the second reason why we use
storyblocks is because all of the things
in their library are royalty free we
have the peace of mind in knowing that
anything we download through that
unlimited all access plan is okay and
good to go and the third reason we use
storyblocks is as a creator you are
going to need a tool to make your videos
more efficient you're gonna run into the
moments where you need hey i just need
these little things to tie my story
together and make it more complete but
they do it at such a higher level that
it just it just works for us if you guys
are interested in getting story blocks
for yourself you can head over to
storyblocks.com
corridor cast or just click the link in
the description below i know i'm wearing
a shirt that says dot com slash corridor
crew but that's just because it's kind
of a joke this one go to
storyblocks.comcast
or just click the link in the
description below uh once again huge
thanks to storyblocks for always
sponsoring this show it is truly a
privilege and a pleasure to be able to
tell you guys about them because we use
them here every day
and you know if you're serious about
creating you may want to consider a
stock asset resource and and we use
storybox so anyways uh thanks for
listening and now let's get back to the
podcast
it goes for all thrones as long as it's
it's it's fully autonomous like at this
point zera is like 98 autonomous
obviously there's like the little like
manual input thing and then there's the
comments that are manual
so like right and and that's i think
that's a good thing to have in place
yeah but like
yeah it also means that if she does
start spewing bad stuff it's like okay
we're liable because like we did we did
you know
of course
autonomy you're basically just like okay
yeah yeah effectively right now sierra
has a pr team yes yeah exactly exactly
yeah and i i honestly think the pr team
is a good thing because i think it's
it's all given how much we've messed
with gpt3 at this point which is her
main speaking ai
like
it's pretty obvious like hey
you know
all you got to do is like give it some
key suggestions and all of a sudden it's
often running into the
you know inflammatory territory very
quickly and and obviously knowing that
like
we want to steer away from that but but
um
man it's just so crazy like the fact
that we were able to build this in like
six weeks i absolutely love it
it came from a joke on the podcast to
begin with yeah
it was a great idea it's it's really
cool that like
well all of us but like that sam
especially can just like make these
crazy ideas
and that that's our job can we just
appreciate that like
we made this freaking robot influencer
and we get to teach people about it yeah
and generate excitement about it and
fear about it and anger
yeah yeah how many how many um
you know would be interesting i don't
know if we want to do this but you know
there's like certain
types of content that are obviously like
more brand friendly or like have a wider
reach for brands
and it given that we can influence her
to be
certain things
as we just saw with the jet ski
experience ambiguous
yeah i wonder if we can like
influence her to start taking on
characteristics that are more like
you know
broadly friendly to like general
audiences brand friendly to general
audiences or
or we influence her the other direction
and then she's just like a huge rebel
who's like you know not afraid to like
say what she means and means what she
says you know type of girl
i don't know
yeah i mean it could go either direction
i feel like
we should we should follow up with some
of these geniuses that have been hitting
us up saying
yeah i want to help you make her even
more autonomous because yeah honestly
like that's the full realization of yeah
i really i really want to make her wiser
why is there a feeder or something i
don't know
i want z to like you know
like you ask her a question and she
gives you a confucian proverb you know
like i want that that's what i was
saying if we feed just all the greatest
minds of all time into the ai it will
combine them all and become this
ai profit
contributing
to the great conversation humanity yeah
we can all flock to
yeah i mean i guess we could feed gtp 3
like all of einstein's works written
works yes the prophet einstein
the prophet
he's just you know
smart guys
that we've collected
through the history of humanity so that
then she can then contribute
a verse of of of truth
into the conversation you know just like
all the greats do
yeah i mean maybe there's some some
questions that he left unanswered in his
notes in his work maybe
maybe she could you know draw those draw
those connecting lines for us yeah yeah
yeah i mean there are some things left
uh
left to be discovered even even with
einstein's theories what a name einstein
i mean
talk about something that's fun to say
einstein it's just taken on its own like
we nailed it with that one it's its own
word now in the english language like we
don't even think of that as a name like
it's like oh okay there's a european
jewish name yeah now it's just like hey
einstein yeah yeah what are you doing
einstein means like sarcastically
nice going einstein
you're like on the east coast and you
pissed someone yeah you spilt the you
spilled the milk all over the floor
step over new york
einstein where are you oh man oh yeah
man yep it's getting weird boys it
really is i love it though i'm leaning
into it 100 yeah whatever comes from it
if it's skynet it is what it is man like
this this is going to happen no matter
what i'm just going to enjoy the ride
yeah you know we're on the inside track
with zr2 i think she'll yeah yeah maybe
now that we have a friend you know in
high school i like how i like how we're
like the ones who are responsible too
for like putting these already existing
features together in a creative format
which let's go way deeper by the way
than like we have access to yeah but
that's the best mentality that you can
have when you're putting together
something like this is to say well if it
you know if it takes over the world you
know it was gonna happen anyway like the
best way to just wipe your hands of it
of something that you're actually going
to just lean into it maybe we should
lean into those comments that are taking
it really seriously and just be like yo
we are we're [ __ ] geniuses
we're gonna make the first one it was
all us
nobody we made gpt three right yeah it's
like guys these are all just like we're
we're basically conserving in the prop
room right now okay the whole thing is
running on a server in the prop room i
mean
basically i went in that prop room for
the first time the other week oh wow
yeah it's uh that's pretty cool up there
a lot of props oh yeah oh that was yeah
yeah you actually like the problem yeah
yeah
know the space bruh i'm sorry sorry guys
sorry the wardrobe area yeah a lot of
props ironically not a lot of room yes
yes yes yeah
but uh yeah but did you see where i
famously hid from everybody using that
very hat that's next to jordan i did i
was oh is this what you used
mm-hmm i think that's the one canadian
ranger that's such a good bit dude oh
this is a strap man was that wait no
that's the that's the ranger one i used
the safari one yeah was that you trying
to be batman yeah yeah yeah that was
just succeeding if i might yeah how dare
you say trying to be sorry that's true
honestly obviously we should go back
recut the uh adam west battle
with jj oh my gosh the one true batman
dude jake
that video man yeah you accidentally
like putting the shoe on your head and
throwing them
we got to do another one man einstein
[Laughter]
i show up with with one of those
disguise kits you know that have
einstein mustache and glasses
and i see if i can fool anybody
i'll pretend to be albert einstein's
grandson
that's true yeah
that sounds like a good video
yeah
we'll just go we'll just go from there
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
christian leans up here he's like
speaking of batman and like
jake starts saying it and we're all like
okay who's doing the he's doing the same
way he's doing the transition
ready one two three speaking of batman
batman
yeah that video is out by the time this
is up right now
it's gonna be live live live so exciting
yeah we just uh just did the little uh
crew preview of it was
nerve-wracking but also very exciting
because that's your first preview of
anything yeah it was pretty cool first
completed like yeah corridor video kind
of i mean man
first wow it felt real
because yeah that's it's a different
thing when you're just a part of the
project
versus everyone watching it yeah with
you there yeah it's that's a little
intimidating yeah yeah so you get your
first
how does it feel like what what's going
through your head like
a
putting work out there for like a
million people which i'm sure you're
kind of used to in a way but this is
like directly yeah but like i feel like
now your face is tight yeah yeah that's
what it is that's it's very intimidating
it's very very intimidating yeah dude
it's so
like this is really interesting because
like i think we all lose perspective on
like what it's like to have a camera
point in your face and like have to like
all the time be on for camera and like
present you're good you're super good at
it by the way thank you yeah jordan's
like a natural like it's very kind day
one it's just like
i mean i don't even think you're putting
anything on that's just you
you know i'm very depressive behind the
scenes
as soon as i leave you didn't strike me
my shoulder
no i actually remember the first time
because i when i came in to start
working here i knew that that was going
to be like a thing like the camera the
camera
and i kind of got in my own head about
it a little bit to where
you know i saw you were running around
with the camera always and the light was
on and like i think halfway through the
week i do a very poor job of being like
hyper focused on problems and then being
like personable
when i'm like super deep diving a topic
i'm not very good at turning that off
yeah instantly and i was trying to
figure out the crowd system in houdini
for the video that ren and i did the uh
for clint's challenge uh with the zombie
horde and i was running into like every
issue possible so i was so deep and like
focused just trying to come on i gotta
try and impress these guys right it's my
one week here
and i felt the light turn on over my
shoulder
and i was so deep in my study i just i
made this choice to just not turn around
i saw it but i just decided like what if
i just don't turn around and just stayed
there for a while you're like oh this is
the shot of me
daniel has made that choice every day
he's been here since he's been here hey
man it's yeah it's a personal choice it
is no yeah it's it's intimidating at
first yeah like when i was down here uh
doing that like star wars video the
first time it was you know the first day
you were just like boom camera i was
like wait are we we're filming it right
now like we're doing it like
talk about vfx do it yeah hey tell me
about the layers yeah compositing yeah
have you found like
uh yeah i think a little bit um nice
it's definitely like i'm still getting
used to it because it's so like
so new to me you know like i've
definitely
um
you know like i worked on the behind the
scenes kind of stuff and now it's like
whoa you're kind of a personality so
yeah it's that part to me is like very
uh i don't know just very different but
i don't like don't dislike it at all
it's definitely enjoyable so
it takes some getting used to for sure
yeah definitely um
yeah it's not a natural thing i think to
be able to do unless you are used to
like public speaking or yeah but it'll
help you and all that stuff for sure i
think it helps you like it does help you
in in all that stuff i i did um
not to brag but i was admitted to my
hometown athletic hall of fame and i had
to do a public speech
when i got
when i got admitted and um i i was able
to sit up there and like not have a
script and like not have any of that and
just talk talk about squarespace
yeah immediately i started and guess
what i got five people there to sign up
for squarespace it was yeah
i'll buy it i love this great yeah but
no it's seriously all of those times of
just you know
cameras on say something figure
something out present a problem present
a solution you know do it don't break
rule number one which is don't be boring
you know like all of those times uh they
have really helped a lot mm-hmm yeah i
didn't get that rule book though yeah
that's the first time i'm hearing about
don't worry all right write that one
down
number one honestly i actually i think i
have somebody requested this uh a while
back
um it's the 10 video commandments oh
yeah
yeah that's a good one sounds helpful
yeah don't be boring it's a big one i
mean you can see a direct correlation i
mean you know
let me see if i can just pull it up
you gotta be on and that's personally
for me that's the hardest part yeah is
like hey
be energetic and also very eloquent yeah
yeah yeah that's it's an odd comment i
don't know and because you're just
talking off the cuff my first jodo was
very sweet today i messed up like a line
while i was you know doing a bit with
him and he's like that's the first time
i've heard you flub which i was like
whoa that's crazy
but yeah it's it's so bizarre just being
like all right camera in your face riff
yeah but actually sound like you know
what you're talking about not just like
that you're like yeah and like it's also
in terms of
how you present the information you have
to like
um really make sure you're
contextualizing everything like you know
like yeah instead of saying like
yeah you know i just i just shift it to
the right it's like okay what are you
shifting why are you shifting it yeah
are you trying to get done yeah what's
the what's the reason what's the
conflict that you're dealing with yeah
so the most the most uh difficult thing
i think in contextualizing is kind of
simplifying some higher level
information when you're talking about
how a process works
it's like
back before i worked here i was a vfx
supervisor and i got very used to
talking directors to directors in a way
that they just didn't want to know
anything except the bare bones you know
what i mean if i went into anything
technical their eyes just glazed over
and the producers were dissatisfied so
it's like one of those things where it's
very it's a very interesting balance to
try and simplify something that is quite
complex
and still keep it you know interesting
yeah i think that's because most
directors don't know visual effects or
because it's just not like the
the process doesn't really require that
or what do you
what do you attribute that to i think it
i think it would
probably be more the latter of or i
guess the former of them not
being too familiar with visual effects
and also the time like there's never
enough time on set obviously uh let
alone to set up visual effects but when
something is changing something's in
flux and they just wanna know can we do
it can we do it you gotta be able to say
yes or no but if it's no you better have
a one sentence answer that will satisfy
or else they're gonna say why yeah why
not what's wrong right i think there's a
lot of directors out there that do not
understand like the vfx process and
that's where the whole like oh we'll fix
it and post process comes from and
you're like dude
just it's going to cost you a lot more
money if you fix it in post like just do
it right on set yeah and it'll become
like a better yeah that's
that's a huge rule
slash lesson learned is
spending five minutes on
spending five minutes doing something on
set
will save you five hours or sometimes
five days
oh yeah yeah and that's you know that's
the language that the producers speak
obviously is money right they're just
trying to be the most effective and get
the best product which i can appreciate
and so yeah when i learned that hey if i
just say yes we can but it will cost you
more
just putting it in those in that context
alone is enough for people to go well
what are our other options you know like
that's all you're really telling that's
really yeah yeah it's an interesting
thing but i you know i get where they're
coming from with it it's just it's it's
a real tough balance sometimes yeah it
is a tough balance because you're also
dealing with this situation where like
every minute on set
is so expensive
you kind of have to pick and choose your
battles sometimes and go like look i
wanna spend five more minutes on this
and i wanna spend five more minutes on
that so that we can save the ten out the
ten collective days later but we
literally only have enough time for one
yeah
today so what do we have to do today
that's more important than
you know what we can fix later um
knowing of course that
that additional time you just added to
your post-production process still costs
you money
but you know it's like picking and
choosing the lesser of two evils a lot
of times where you're just trying to
figure out what's gonna hurt less
after the videos in the can
yeah
nick am i did you like direct a film
like i did yeah like how was that
process for you did you find well i
don't know how vfx heavy it was it's not
vfx heavy luckily it was totally you
know a low budget indie thing we're
still i'm actually just
it's funny on monday yesterday i just
was doing my vfx list oh
yeah it's all about are you running into
things that you're like oh man i wish
we'd done this differently on set or was
it like yeah actually i mean one of the
one of the things was and i started
filming like a little vlog with daniel
about this and stuff but never panned
out was like the license plate like we
have to do it's dumb stuff like that
clean outs yeah and we're so low budget
we couldn't get a license plate made so
i tried to
print a license plate because like the
picture car we were using had the actual
person's license plate so
you go through this process where you
submit your script um
and it's clear it's basically insurance
clearance you have to pay this company
to do it and they go through and make
sure all the names numbers talked about
this actually before in a lot on a
previous one but they they will assign
you
custom like phone numbers or addresses
or license plate numbers
that you know aren't registered with
anyone these are cleared for use in your
film now
across all boards like you're not
legally liable you can take this all the
way to the end of you know selling the
film and everyone will be assured that
this license plate you're good so we
printed it
and it was like the day before the shoot
and i was like all right all i have to
do like we printed it i like sprayed it
down with white spray paint i had the
prop ready to go and i was like no i
just need to put the blue accents on it
yeah and um it's like the day before we
had to like shoot this intense scene
where you would see it
and like i go to try to find blue paint
jake and i was like
running through the studio tearing
through all of our paints in all of our
shelves like there has to be some
goddamn blue paint here and there's no
blue paints
wait you could just make blue paint
though can't you no there was literally
nothing like i tried mixing up some
greens and stuff and like you know yeah
it didn't work it did not work dude it
looks like it's there you can see it it
looks like garbage it looks like poop
just like it like dried like brown it's
just horrible what was supposed to be
blue then well like the california
license plate wait we didn't have any
there's you could take it i know spray
paint and sprayed it on a
paper paper plate and i was so frazzled
and i had like i had allocated 15
minutes in my mind in my plan for the
whole night and day of like rushing to
prep or shoot yeah oh i know to doing
this i was like yeah i know we have
acrylic paint at the studio i'll just
get a little paintbrush that i i know
it's on the shelf right there i know the
paint's right there i'll just go in and
i'll do it real quick let it dry yeah
and then you've got it just got you then
got me and i was just like nope and i
just threw the plate and i'm like we'll
just do in post well i know i know that
it's in hindsight so it doesn't have no
benefit now but did you uh
think about using a different color and
just hue shifting it input god damn it
you know like
the affection of jesus is replaced
and just you know there's nothing no you
just
think about that because i'm a director
and i don't have visual effects literacy
like you do well that's that's why we
need to work together man yeah that's
actually
that's actually my next question is
since you've it's like andrew kramer's
third tutorial by the way guys you're
shifting license plates things it's one
of his best colors
yes but uh have you felt like working i
know i've spoke with dean a lot about
this but he's felt like working here
has improved his knowledge around visual
effects dramatically have you felt that
on set where okay i actually feel like i
have a grasp on the newspaper
yeah for sure i mean i feel like i could
borderline vf and this is
obviously i'm not totally serious about
this but i could like get around being a
vfx soup on like a low budget thing i
could be like yeah like i know how to
get plates i know what you need to shoot
for what elements you need to capture
because i mean
it's been
we've we've been we've been doing it for
a while so especially with the react
show dude yeah totally you cover every
topic and you know they say what it
takes like three times
for something to sink in
so once you hear about all these various
techniques over and over it just sinks
in you're on episode like 100 something
something yeah and it's cool to hear
that from our audience too like that's
the coolest part obviously we say this a
lot about the show is like
normal people are grasping these
concepts yeah it's pretty cool it like
kind of you know
you know takes down the curtain a little
bit like it's i don't know i mean just
even hearing you talk about like the
stuff like license plates represent
like because i would love to be able to
get into a point where i'm directing my
own projects at some point totally but i
mean that's something i would never even
think of is like license plates phones
like i'm like wow that's like there's a
lot of like weird legal loopholes that
you know you realize oh it's actually
there's good reason for
the the hell of pre-production because
like you got to really set yourself up
for success yeah i can talk about more
about setting yourself up for success
we've been learning some valuable
lessons in this process but yeah the
movie's still going along we're slowly
pushing the train getting we have a
couple vfx shots we got to do very easy
stuff
but
i wanted to actually throw it back to
you guys because you guys come from a
like
actual industry vfx background
whereas the rest of us at quarter crew
don't we all just came up doing we just
made it all up yeah
like
but it's interesting because like
so i read
a there's like a comment on i forget
which video but it was it was from a guy
and he was very angry and
this is why
because
he was i remember this guy yeah yeah i
told you a bit about he he was teaching
vfx in a school i don't know where
and all of his students he said were he
called them corridor kids
and they were
all hyped up on vfx from watching our
videos which to me this was like boom
okay well we're actually having this
effect in like classrooms what the frick
like
you kind of don't like realize i guess
what reach or what effect you're having
but like this was an interesting insight
it was like it got my attention i was
like oh okay you're teaching a bunch of
kids who are inspired by our videos
directly
and he said he quit his job because of
the corridor kids
why what was his reason because all they
wanted to do was watch youtube and yeah
work ethic so for me i'm thinking to
myself
this is
this could be any [ __ ] class
i feel like i know the teacher you're
talking okay
you may no no and i'm interested to hear
this though because i feel like what
you know what it did for me is make me
realize okay we actually
we're having ripples now throughout an
actual like vfx industry or the next
generation
is there something we could actually do
or would it be worth our while to put
efforts into actually making videos
addressing this that are like so you
want to get into vfx kid well here are
the actual programs you should train
here's the actual things that will equip
you better to go into an education
to be in the actual industry and i mean
making yeah you know videos on the
internet is probably a different path
from that but i mean it just seems like
yeah it made me think about that how we
can do that awesome it's kind of like
functional filmmaking around two almost
like yeah but like
your side of things it's just like do we
but at the same time it's it's kind of
like the angry guy who emailed us was
actually it was fenner
and then we won him over
no i think i think it if i don't think
it actually is but the
when i was teaching the person i
replaced was very much a bitter kind of
dude please can you can you expand
afterwards i would love to see the name
of the person that even okay that'd be
so small
and like yeah and he's very like
prominent on like the vfx
subreddits and social media so yeah i
honestly wouldn't it could be the same
person because
yeah it's just you know it's a massive
industry but it's like a very small
industry on the same way yeah it's just
it's crazy to think like
you know what we what we put out there
it does have an impression on people
obviously we know this but like
i just feel like
part of the charm comes from the fact
that we are so
pro-sumer or whatever like we're just
like kind of breaking the barrier to
entry for people who maybe are really
you know just getting interested in it
or just casually yeah interested in this
stuff so like we we've never marketed
ourselves as like this is film school
this is gonna you know no we're gonna
teach you what you need to succeed in
this industry there's a lot of reasons
why we haven't marketed
anything we do on that number one
because we we don't really feel like
we
want to um
it's not as fun that's the main thing is
it's like it's not as interesting to
the general viewer
to like go hard into
the the the techniques
you know the the the technical side of
it
how it's done
and the other that so that's reason
number one and then reason number two is
really like
it depends on what level you're doing
visual effects at like there's nothing
wrong with like
doing v effects from some footage you
got with your phone
there's nothing more inherently
better or worse about that
as there is in doing visual effects that
you shot on a giant blue screen
on a huge set with all these moving
parts like you're just doing it at a
different scale and and those scales
have different schools of thought you
know
and so
i don't know if a lot of people know
that just because it is a niche thing
but that's a super important like side
of it that we don't really discuss
it's yeah it's uh i mean corridor to me
has always kind of represented
this really fun like open field of just
the reason
so so so many of us i think fenner and
myself included in that got into visual
effects in the first place which is just
what can you do what is fun what is
enjoyable yeah but kind of to your point
yeah a lot of people
who are just entering are watching this
stuff and like yeah they get wrong
impressions do they get
well it's hard to say it's interesting
that you're like oh we're starting to
have this ripple effect like corridor
and i already have like i mean that's a
huge part of the reason i work in dfx is
because of corridor wow and it's you
know there's a lot of pitfalls on the
way up in visual effects i mean uh fener
can certainly speak to like the
commercial pipeline of things and that
ladder and i can kind of speak to the
freelance side of navigating just kind
of solo what's working and what's not
working and trying to figure out these
relationships and there's so many
lessons there
to be learned it's kind of a lot to take
on but you know kind of smaller topics
like uh daniel did an incredible job
helping me create the learning how to
learn on the website which is very dear
to my heart which is more just a
breakdown of
how you actually go about doing it alone
you know and like just the tools to get
you started but i think beyond that
it's it's a personal thing you know like
how much do you want it are you gonna
wake up in the morning are you gonna
pursue this knowledge because no one's
gonna spoon feed it to you yeah and you
could watch a hundred videos in a row
with all the technique there you will
not retain that
you won't you need to actually get up
and you need to do it and
and that i don't think you can give to
anybody well yeah i think it's like i
mean it's funny saying this as someone
that was a vfx teacher but i don't
actually think
in this day and age you need to go to
like film school to become a vfx artist
like i don't either yeah so much amazing
information online and for tutorials
like
i mean i feel like if you really applied
yourself
and cut together an amazing demo reel
like just from stuff you've learned off
youtube videos like
i mean yeah i mean maybe it's not with
the proprietary software that's being
used at the studio but i mean jordan
like you picking up nuke because you
understood after effects as long as you
understand those core concepts you can
transfer that over to another program
that might be used at a like large film
studio it's actually a really good point
because all the things tied together all
the disciplines tie together so you
start on i think i started on windows
movie maker and figured out slow motion
and my my brain exploded with excitement
and i figured out you know how to cut
and final cut okay well now moving on to
premiere and oh well these shortcuts
transfer okay i understand what i'm
looking for after effects moving on to
cinema 4d understanding 3d cinema 4d
into houdini okay different world
houdini now to nuke that is very similar
and like you start to speak these
languages but it just takes time it
takes reps and to fender's point now
there is such incredible resource online
like
you know stephen nipping is one of the
people who i learned houdini from from
his online courses on cg circuit and
he's the guy who's doing he's like
supervising uh or is a technical
director for the star wars films like
overseeing these explosions and then
teaching you how to make explosions in
houdini yeah and there's no
like that's the best teacher you could
possibly have right and you know i can
email him and he'll respond okay well
now i don't need
because who who there has a but who's
more active in the in the world of
visual effects than him right now yeah
you know what i mean and that i think
that course was like seventy dollars
that was another thing that's amazing
people
that was another thing like especially
sam and nico were harped on this a lot
when i
you know was like hey maybe we should go
more into the
like school
tutorial
route
the other thing that they often said was
like look like there's already these
guys out there advising stuff are so
amazing that are doing it at such a high
level already that if we were to go out
there and put our foot in that water it
would basically be like you know a huge
a huge it's a if you think like making
videos like how we make them and how we
distribute them
if you don't realize like that's a
full-time thing for all of us to do
collectively
doing the tutorial levels
doing the tutorials at that level
is also the same level of commitment
and so you kind of have to choose like
which one do you want to
which type of of thing do you want to
contribute you know and and so we just
for us totally the more natural decision
was to do things that were more like the
exhibition of the use of the tool rather
than the education of the tool but we
owe those people like
you know totally so much this is hard
it's hard to contextualize when you see
people
who you look up to in any field
when you're especially when you're young
because you you've only lived a certain
amount of years you're the oldest you're
the oldest that you've ever experienced
being so understanding more time and
more effort and more energy dedicated to
one particular thing isn't really
possible you know when you're younger
it's only when you've kind of traveled
up the road
that you realize how much you don't know
and how much they must have studied to
learn what they know and so as a kid
looking in on youtube it's like yeah
they're making awesome stuff i want to
make awesome stuff well that's the very
beginning of the road which is awesome
it's great to be inspired like that but
there's a long trek of things that you
need to understand before you're capable
of doing this stuff and i yeah i i guess
just pressing that message home of
it's super fun but it is it's a
technical skill set and it takes work i
i feel like that would be an interesting
video to make with you two as the
central characters because like a video
that's like what it's actually like
working in the vfx industry
i feel like that could help maybe you
know
real people's expectations and of like
okay because there's two paths right i'm
a kid who's inspired by corridor i can
either go the youtube or corridor route
or i'm like i'm going to take classes
and try to like learn you know
let's give this a shot i'll go to school
my parents want me to go to school so
i'll go vfx school and then you're
sitting in a class and you know they're
like okay let's learn nuke or houdini
and you're like what corduroy just uses
after effect yeah you know so like not
anymore yeah well not anymore but like
but that's like you know well yeah it's
slowly changing but yeah i just
and again there's like there's nothing
we can do about that i think i don't
know if there's anything inherently
wrong with that though like you know
like what's wrong with what's wrong with
a kid seeing a video thinking that it's
awesome and then wanting to do visual
effects yeah they might realize later
like hey it's it's not the path for me
but other people like fenner perfect
example somebody saw our videos became
inspired to do them taught himself it
wasn't i'm sure there were points where
you got discouraged with it fenner or
you realize like hey this is actually
gonna be you know i'm gonna need to know
this or i'm gonna need to do that
it's not just all like the glamour and
the youtube videos and the the views and
the brand integration money and all the
crap you know
it's like i mean
why don't you speak to that directly
yeah yeah absolutely i mean i'd like i
ended up going to uh like a film school
think tank training center in vancouver
and it was it was awesome but i mean
when i was there uh especially because
we didn't start learning compositing
until the second semester i was like oh
man i don't like i'm not gonna be able
to make anything like because i would
see like
oh like quarter or what you know some
big film just came out
like i remember while i was at the
school me and a bunch of my classmates
went and saw interstellar and i was just
like oh no
what like how do i
how do i do anything like what what
it's just like there's my goal and here
i am yeah and then i'm modeling like
this janky elephant in maya
you have those moments where you're like
i know what i want to do i just don't
know how to do it and that's not because
you're
dumb or you're not skilled enough it's
just a matter of time and it's like
it takes so much time and the biggest
thing that i think is like
a lot of people uh struggle with is like
you don't know what you don't know
and that's what's like the only way you
figure that out is by doing it because
you like run into a project and you're
like i don't know how to do this i have
to learn how to do this and that's how
you grow as an artist and yeah just as a
person in life like
yeah and um that's why i'm huge on like
project based learning i think that's
super helpful because
as you move through your journey you run
into these problems and if you've run
into them before
if you have them associated with
something
chances are that you'll retain the
knowledge a lot better if it's like oh
this is the issue i ran into when i was
trying to make the building explode oh i
understand okay i can apply this now but
before that you don't have that so now
you're scrambling the internet and we've
all been there trust me we're just
trying to figure out how to make it work
and yeah i remember like my first year
in in houdini
every day i'd have headaches like
genuinely because it's so different than
anything i'd learned before so i would
learn to the point of my head hurting
and then i'd go take a nap and lie down
and then i'd wake up and i'd do it again
and
i had so much free time because it was
like pandemic time
so i just continued to ram my head into
this seemingly concrete wall and like
one day
my girlfriend can attest i just called
her and i said i think i'm beginning to
get it like i cracked the wall just a
little bit and i was like oh it's
possible okay it's still a huge concrete
wall but i'm gonna keep going and i'm
still head-butting it you know but
there's a lot more cracks in it now
so it's one of those things where it's
just the reps like totally what you're
saying just it's time in the program
like exposure the best way to learn a
language right is to move to that
country and be immersed in it it's the
same idea with any of the technical
stuff just immerse yourself in it and if
you're there long enough it'll start to
click it'll start to make sense we
definitely have that
that theory here we learn by doing and
like almost any like of the challenges
or like projects
it's all like
figuring it out that goes back to kind
of what we were saying with conflict
earlier
we were having a discussion jake earlier
yeah yeah about
how dang good these guys are and
like you guys knocked out that batman
video in like a week
back to the batman video check it out
it's so polished and like
that is i mean
it's definitely a shift from my
perspective because
we have been always a
learn by doing we're generalists so
we're going to learn by doing and
the results might take a while and they
might look a bit janky
however
you guys just knocked out this like
super polished short
we didn't get the learning though that's
the thing about that video is like i
feel like
with the quarter crew videos it's that
it's the process of learning and what
you don't know that makes the results
like
even if they're a little bit un like
half baked or you didn't have enough
time because we have to make all these
things in a week
like that's what makes the results
valuable to like the viewer and to the
artist
which is funny because fenner was
teaching me nuke for that yeah
jordan then just was like sweet
and i was like nice like yeah you're too
good at learning man
to that point it's like maybe
i mean for myself again i want to keep
learning and growing as an artist and
it's like maybe just being more
ambitious with the videos so by all
means yeah yeah i mean i'd say getting
out of your comfort zone is the perfect
opening for a video because yeah yeah
it's sure to be a an interesting watch
yeah i mean i feel like the next video
we have planned is definitely it's it's
ambitious it's ambitious so it's
definitely you guys want to tease it a
little bit yeah how much how much can we
divulge on this as much as you want this
is really i'm just going to say this
this is the trouton chorus
want to keep getting the insights then
if the podcast ever blows up then we're
gonna have to start like another podcast
a sub podcast
yeah because this is where all the
insights are are discussed
yeah fenner had a great idea of uh what
if the storm troopers like had uh had
eye care provided to them so they could
actually shoot straight
which is a great concept
lasik laser laser eye therapy yeah lasik
therapy and so yeah the idea is
basically centered around look what
would the war have looked like if they
could actually shoot
and it turns out it doesn't last very
long yeah so
i mean i think we are being more
ambitious with this and i think for
myself just in the wanting to become a
better filmmaker not just a vfx artist i
was like okay i guess i'm editing this
thing and because matt's also so busy
like he crushed it on the batman video
which was a huge help for us um but now
i'm like okay i'm i'll edit this thing
like we'll see how it goes and
it's a lot of a lot of cg which is i'm
you know i know cg but i'm primarily
like in nuke so it's you know full cg
shots yeah um which we'll be pushing
ourselves and then jordan's doing some
pretty awesome yeah like simulations
yeah i'm getting into the new houdini
ragdoll
simulations and like my one of my
biggest goals going into this project
again learning by doing right is
to finally wrap my head around the
system to where i can plug in any scan
of any of us or any other character and
instantly have a fully operational
ragdoll and yeah that we we managed to
break that
down enough to where where we can now
yeah legit legitimately all the star
wars characters literally literally like
right now i can plug all the star wars
characters into my rig and have an
entire cast of ragdolls that i can
completely customize and control and
throw against walls and throw through
things and
yeah dude it's i'm like that was by far
my favorite win
the old way to do this is to literally
just do everyone individually exactly
and so like houdini is just like nuke
procedural man it's like
that's the beauty of it so you know you
can also
like tether them to things
with things called constraints right you
can tie i think of like you can tie them
all to like windmill blades and just
have them like like just
you can tie like certain parts of their
bodies and you can control other parts
of their bodies to resist and try to you
know if you if you curl one up in a ball
you can give its muscles strength to
stay in the ball and so as you're
throwing it down it's like being forced
open as it's hitting things but it's
recoiling back into it crazy it's like
man the the possibilities are just so
exciting from it so yeah stuff like that
that wouldn't have been possible if you
know we didn't have an idea that was
kind of stretching our comfort yeah
definitely in that regard it's it's
funny too because i'm struggling with
finding that balance like okay we got to
push ourselves and try to learn and do
new things be ambitious
and then that leads us to being able to
have a good product for the crew channel
as well because it is real
and we are struggling up against it but
then also struggling with like okay i
still want it to be a good looking
product at the end of it yeah right so
the batman video like i'm pretty happy
with how that ended up looking and it's
like
how do you maintain that quality bar
while still pushing yourself like so
that's something i'm going to try to
find the best one is very very fast
everybody he's very very fast
so like he humbled me on this you know
yeah yeah fenner put like you're you've
been putting all your points into that
end product yeah but like i think it's
just
like
just the conversations we've been having
here and earlier today was like just the
mentality of like okay how do i open
this up to like take people along on the
journey you know with me yeah and let
them learn with me basically yeah
definitely just being aware of that you
know totally yeah such an adjustment
yeah for sure
the nice thing about the corridor crew
format that we were restricted with with
just the corridor format is that say
you're working on this piece
and you get to a point where you're like
okay i'm or maybe it's an even bigger
piece you know maybe it's a few months
from now and it's like okay now we're
doing something even crazier you know
well
we can release things in parts too
on chord or crew
that
aren't necessarily like hey here's the
completed end product the whole creative
story and
you know
and we're and we're going to release the
completed end product on the corridor
channel
we can do that obviously if if they're
all done at the same time like we can do
that but one of the nice things about
the crew format is that you can you can
stop you can have like a natural ending
or stopping point and sort of chapter a
journey out
as long as that journey has you know
sort of
like
an end goal per chapter that people can
can grab on to that we can mark it after
yeah definitely it's so funny like it's
for me it's shifting into that mindset
because coming from like the uh like vfx
studio environment it's like get
everything done as quickly as possible
and like it's inter it's it's amazing
here to be like okay
get it done
but like also like
don't stress out too much and also just
like
you know enjoy the ride and enjoying
that ride you have to like you know be
showing your process as well
yeah because yeah i mean the more of
that stuff the more struggle obviously
the better the story so yeah
um yeah i mean
but the product like the fact that you
know you guys have been
making such high quality stuff is like
just the the cherry on top i think so um
yeah man it's really cool i'm i'm i
could talk
for so long about like the differences
between because like i'm really
interested in what those differences are
between like you know the actual vfx
industry
and what you know what we kind of
make what we do is yeah and not like
again like i'm not saying we need to
mold ourselves to that it's just like i
want to set people up for success who
are
inspired by us because
you know it's apparent that that is
happening
so it's like okay well how because like
we don't need to like conform to the vfx
industry but like
if we're gonna affect it we should at
least like not
cause problems
when it comes to likes if i'm a kid
who's
inspired i want to be told like
what's the format that i need to shoot
my video at like like i i don't want a
youtuber to
to tell me to go shoot on 16 millimeter
film and then i show up at film school
and they're like no we're shooting on
sony's you know yeah
you know
it's just that basic level of like how
can we set people up for success if they
do want to you know i mean i mean i feel
like i feel like corridor does because
the biggest thing to set yourself up for
success is just starting like
you just got to start doing it right
like that's the whole the classic
investment thing is like yeah um
time in the market beats timing the
market like you just gotta if you're
like oh i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in you
know next year and i mean i'm doing it
myself i'm like with a i had a note in
my phone learn unreal engine 4 for the
longest time because i was like oh
that's awesome and i'm like
unreal engine 5's out
so like
that's a big thing i want to push myself
this year to get into because it's been
like
two years just start yeah just start i
just have to start so yeah yeah okay
well you know it's interesting i don't
know
well what's what's also nice about
corridor kind of as like that lighthouse
on the hill is that it shows what what a
few people can do because kind of what
fenrir was talking about earlier going
into a movie i did that all the time
dude go into a movie watch this high-end
friggin triple-a production with
thousands of artists and just compare
them to me
why why am i doing that why am i sitting
there watching avatar going why can't i
do that well there's a lot of reasons
sit down you're not a thousand what am i
doing wrong you're not a thousand people
who are at the peak of you know their
learning potential like it's okay and
but when you go watch avatar two by sam
gorski
[Laughter]
yeah there it is yeah you can grasp it
it's really cool because it's it you
know you see something that's just
still absolutely incredible to watch and
i remember when i was younger watching
court was the same thing like you just
watch this stuff you're like oh my gosh
i remember the uh the wizards uh the
wizards who drank too much potion
throwing up the liquid scene
that was like what nine years ago ten
years ago something crazy oh man you
haven't been you are oh dude i'm i'm
long time and uh you know i remember
watching that going
i could do that like
if i learn about this i can do that at
some point and it was so much more
relatable and attainable because it's
people that i knew you know it's people
that i would watch and see their
troubles and see them overcoming things
see them working late and like because
that's the thing too you see like you
see ren working late into the night like
you see
yeah you know it's not like we're okay
there's a little bit of that grind okay
100 yeah we're not just saying like oh
you know
all
right
you have 30 minutes go make something
and then we you know create this
incredible
it's not like that so
like i got it watching that it was it's
still a grind like it's what it takes to
to make it so yeah i mean yeah our
mindset has always been like the
programs don't matter like it's it's
what you do with it's just a tool right
they use any as much as i'm like oh we
gotta use nuke i'm like man if you can
do it in after effects if you can do it
in premiere resolve you can do it in ms
paint do it like another paint would be
good i will say the new composites look
that's the thing i think it's under
understated what yeah it's like yeah
yeah nuke nuke might be your ferrari or
whatever right but but
what are you trying to do with the tool
and so that's more important
understanding what the tool and nico
talks about this
gives very good examples in his
functional filmmaking episode which is
available for free on corridor youtube
if anyone wants to watch it
it's also available for free on the
website but anyways he goes into this
detail about how okay if you're gonna
shoot something you know that's gonna be
um
like the blair witch project
right you don't need
a red camera
on
rails and a dolly
to shoot that you need a handheld
dslr
that's going to give you the image
quality
and the style of image that you're
looking for the same thing applies to
software visual effects programs and any
creative tool really like it's just what
are you trying to do and
are you utilizing the the best tool the
tool that's going to give you the most
accurate results for that end image that
you're looking to achieve yeah totally
and and just like what you're
i don't know comfortable with as well
because if yes
like
uh if you're jumping into a new program
trying to get something done then maybe
your results aren't going to be as good
in a program that maybe is not as like
industry standard but it's like
you know if
i wouldn't want you like jumping into
nuke like the batman video was awesome
because you were learning nuke but it's
like i wouldn't want you jumping into
son of a dungeon being like oh man i
could do this better in after effects
because if you could like and you wanted
to then that's the program you should
use right
like i mean it's fun like myself my like
the cg software i like using is blender
and people in the industry are like well
blender and it's like dude it's the
program i like and it works for me so
that's yeah it's a yeah it's
there's yeah there's there's some level
of it where it's definitely used the
right tool for the job
i think you know i think like
large-scale simulations in houdini
you're gonna have a way better time than
you will elsewhere
in photoshop
exactly
but that said like hey man it's all just
what you want
don't be doing if all you have is my
point is my point is if all you have is
photoshop don't be trying to do
something that requires large-scale
crap that's a fair bit of advice yeah
change your creativity to fit your tool
know what tools you can accomplish
that's the reality is like you know
coming up if you have everything at your
fingertips chances are like right out
the gate like nothing kind of earned so
to speak
chances are you will
really suffer creatively
because
creativity thrives in a box like when
when you put boundaries around like time
limit or
you know what what you're able to do or
what you're able to accomplish you have
to be creative with those tools and like
that creativity is the real value
honestly because
once you have access to the bigger tools
once you have an understanding of some
of the fundamental aspects you've
already trained your creativity
and now you can unleash it in even more
insane ways and that's really what will
take you i was thinking it'd be fun
we're
doing the satisfying renders right now i
think it'd be a really fun video to do
satisfying renders but you can't use a
cg software package
so like go back to classic just like
play like clay stop seriously cuts like
jump cuts like try to do a satisfying
render but without
blender houdini c4d like
after effects and nuke like for the comp
side of things i think still
um but i feel like that would be really
fun of trying to do like yeah like vfx
magic basically yeah yeah totally like
you know the
i don't know just all of the classic
kind of things or like
you know i mean going through the star
wars just trying to take tremendous just
trying to take 3d off the table so that
he's got more of a chance i see what's
going on i mean yeah i i had the idea
for uh a render challenge to just all
switch softwares yes because that'll
people if people think that it just
comes to you naturally
that'll humble everybody because if you
put me in blender i'm a dunce i'm no
einstein let me tell you i think that's
a good hey this guy
brought it back
i think that's a good that would be a
good exercise internally that would make
a terrible video fair it's just a it's
just a fire from a lot of anger no
resolution no quality yeah at the end
that's fair all right are you guys ready
for these ten creative commandments
laid on me now i so a couple words on
this before i before i read these off
number one uh i adapted these from um
i believe it was the bodybuilder uh the
guy who's famous for saying ain't
nothing but a little bitty peanut do you
know who i'm talking
about does anybody know what he's
talking about
hold on
[Music]
i love that you said that like it's
common knowledge
come on guys this guy's pretty famous
um
yeah ronnie coleman
ronnie
dude ronnie coleman is like the most
intense
he's so intense and so he came up with
these 10 bodybuilding lightweight
commandments
yes
yeah
lightweight boy
yeah yeah uh lightweight baby
lightweight
but a peanut yeah yeah ate nothing but a
little bitty peanut looks like he lifted
it
he'd lift like 400 pounds and then drop
it and go ain't nothing but a little
bitty peanut um
so anyway he had these ten commandments
and i thought they were super intense
and cool so then i adopted them to um
video creating um now these are a few
years old there may be some some things
here and there that you know
my point is adapt these how you may but
here here they are all right number one
it's actually it's not don't be boring
that's from a different thing but that
is rule number one rule number
zero don't be boring rule number one
create you are commanded to create say
it and believe it
rule number two question
never accept the limitations of what
others believe to be possible decide it
for yourself
rule number three
revising
revising is an inescapable pain
only out of revision are great things
born
number four
listen learn to listen to your creative
instincts and they will speak to you
number five focus
get a clear picture in your mind of what
you want to create pick your goal and
stick to it
that that allows you to actually produce
things
in a tangible way and not just be stuck
in projects forever
number six change
change is necessary people will stop
watching if you do the same thing all
the time convince the audience that
there is something new they will like
seven
angles
angles are everything and all are unique
changing an angle can change the world
overload
overload the world with your creations
leave them guessing what you will come
up with next
number nine obsession if you want to be
the absolute best you must be obsessed
with it you cannot be interested you
cannot be
somewhat into it you have to be obsessed
with it if you want to be the best
satisfaction number 10
be
confident and
okay
with what you've done
but never become satisfied with what
you've done well that's my favorite one
satisfaction is the end of your creative
journey whoa i like that yeah yeah cause
that's yeah that's that's a that's a big
thing
that you know i know i've personally
dealt with is
imposter syndrome i heard you mention
that today fenner as well like
especially when you're you know you're
no longer in the shadows of the vfx
world like being on camera in front of
all your peers and people that you just
tremendously respect and kind of being
exposed in everything that you do
is very scary and it's very easy to get
in your own head about it and say i'm
not good enough and why am i here why me
shouldn't be me and like yeah quelling
those thoughts and like doing it anyway
and
being proud of what you've done and like
really becoming more insular and how
you're approaching these things and
looking at how far you've personally
come instead of constantly comparing to
everyone else out there
and again saddling that with never being
satisfied where you continue to want
more and want more and want more but be
proud of yourself like that's a that's a
real tough thing to come to terms with
but when you do when you start to make
peace with yourself in that way it just
you explode like it's it's so good and
healthy yeah you know
yeah that's a good point too is like
never compare yourself to other people
only compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
yeah comparison that one's really
important
yeah i even tell my my kids that yeah
you know when they go oh wow i can't do
that or i you know that kid can do that
and i can't do it or so no no no it's
not about what they can do it's about
what you can do and what you could do
now and what you could do yesterday that
the same thing applies when you get
older
yeah yeah and it's like the another
thing
is you know in the comparative world
when you are seeing
these amazing things that people are
doing it's just that is evidence of what
you can do
one day right if you continue to push
and continue to pursue that should be a
light at the end of the tunnel not
something that makes you shy away not
want to play anymore
that should be encouraging that should
be like a lure you know yeah and yeah
that healthy mindset
like that that combination is really
powerful so yeah i like that 10th rule
that's that's a win for yeah that's a
that one stood out for sure
never
never
be
overly confident in the work that you've
made yeah because
you're not setting yourself up for for
more growth at all
no yeah that's it once
i created the best thing and that's it
and no one else will ever it's like nope
you're done you've contributed to your
verse step aside
yeah
like how many filmmakers who are
successful or people in our field
have you met who are like yeah dude what
i just made is [ __ ] it's perfect
it's perfect i'm done have you ever met
someone who didn't i don't think i've
ever seen any creatives
thankfully
yeah if you have they probably suck
yeah i think that's that's it's like
and
i mean i've run into it before but again
the like successful part is the asterix
there it's like
yeah you're not you're literally not
gonna go anywhere like
cause
you're the only one
with that thought basically
yeah like you know it's just
you might you might find him yeah what
was that uh do you watch uh channel five
with uh andrew the youtube channel his
uh stuff is awesome yeah it's the follow
up to all gas no breaks when oh yes dude
i love that guy yeah yeah yeah so it's
it's andrew he started a new channel
it's called channel 5. it's
even better than the old one
but i can't remember if it was on
uh all gas no breaks or if it was on his
new channel but he went to that like
hype vape
soundcloud rapper convention do you
remember that i i don't remember what
was a complex con complex yes yes wow
there were some there were some people
there that he interviewed that were like
that insane you know like that that like
oh yo
well i feel like that's like like for
every humble person you meet in la you
get the the person who like
who
topped out their hometown like they
maxed out their hometown clout level and
they're just like yeah let's go to la
baby and they're just so [ __ ] high on
themselves
and that's what it was complex con yeah
do you think those people though they
believe it like have they tricked
themselves into believing it are they
just doing the fake it till you make it
like yeah i think it's a mix i don't
know i think so i think they just had
few too many hits of methamphetamines
yeah the truly delusional ones
i think also like sometimes
some people see people because there's a
rare amount of people who do just
[ __ ]
bs their way to the top yeah and it's
just their ego that gets them work
because again fake it till you make it
yeah so like there are some people who
are now role models of the i'm the [ __ ]
everyone else sucks
uh i'm the voice of a generation
mentality
and yeah i mean you can't blame them for
wanting to be like them i guess but
i don't know i i don't see anyone
succeed that way
yeah i've never seen personally anyone
succeed that way that's for sure
but they like to talk about themselves a
lot that's for sure yeah i just thought
it was a funny tidbit oh so if you
haven't seen channel five definitely
check it out it's amazing yeah some of
the best some of the best journalism
i've ever seen and he hardly says a word
yeah just let people go most people dig
their own holes
like i feel like we should send that
whole channels like all their videos
like on hard drive into space so just
like yes if one thing survives let's
just like
just so we can see you know
seriously
where aliens know about us
you will learn more about the world
watching that channel yes
there's a few others that are doing some
some good stuff out there but that's
that's one of them man i feel like
there's a lot of rip offs of anders
videos um especially
yeah but they're definitely holding it
down they just know who i discovered
today though um
what was the guy let me pull up my
channel this this guy basically
whoa apparently i feel like we need
those ten commandments that's like
plaques yeah we should get we should get
a plaque we might want to i'll i'll put
them in here i'll put them in the
description of this video if anyone's
interested
and um maybe we just have it printed on
a bust i'm out ronnie coleman for the
corner of the office with einstein he's
lifted
that would be it 3d print it let's do it
like a newborn calf yeah just to
ronnie coleman lifting
oh what is he lifting he's lifting
einstein he's like
like einstein's holding
he's holding the flags
look at this guy he's a real einstein
he's just doing this
in the statue
hey get a load of him
all right are you guys ready to to get
played out of here is there anything
else we need to say we need to say to
the to the world
um uh i need the bathroom
thanks for
watching thanks for watching everybody
uh ten commandments are in the
description uh ten creative commandments
and also thank you ronnie coleman thank
you thank you to everybody who's ever
taught anyone anything about visual
effects online myself included um thank
you thank you for uh giving us the
knowledge uh that we have to uh make
videos
thank you you got to start playing
yourself out now jake that speech is
getting a little bit
sorry buddy is that too much all
right myself out hey if you guys have
any other uh commandments that you've
thought of that have helped you leave
them in the comments because i know we
could probably uh maybe learn something
from that so love it yeah definitely can
you sing about ronnie coleman
did you play us out
[Music]
light weight
baby
baby
light weight
baby
[Music]
a little peanut maracas that way baby
that's beautiful wow
man we should form a band
i'm still upset that you're eating
something called tails and it's not just
tails yeah wait these are i don't know
what they did here if you guys are still
listening can you show me the cut
yeah
i hope he didn't cut fish tails fish
tails what the frick is not just tails
it's not they're called tails and it
says two flavors in one but then it's a
whole swedish fish so it's not just
because you'd expect two flavors of a
tail yeah i want two tails
i don't know what they were thinking
when they called it oh
on the back side it says that their sour
patch kids also try sour patch kids
heads
no
you're going to be seven years in one
it's going to be at multicultural take
the feet thank you very much also two
flavors in one
i consider myself a gummy aficionado
i've never heard of this oh my god i
gotta stop eating these there's 27
carbohydrates in five of these okay 27
carbohydrates
there's 27 carbohydrates
wow we're done
we're done yeah let's get out of here